the new school year has just begun kids
adjusting to their new lunch routines
but what should parents keep in mind to
keep those lunches both fresh and
healthy joining us this morning meredith
caruthers a food safety expert with the
usda
and meredith you know with the cost of
food nobody wants to have to throw
anything out because it's spoiled so
it's so important to make sure we're
packing those lunches correctly what can
parents do
absolutely so in addition to not wanting
to waste any food we also want to make
sure nobody's getting sick from
foodborne illness especially your kids
so the biggest thing that you can add to
your back-to-school list this year is
your freezer packs or anything that's
going to be a cold source to keep your
kids lunch cold also considering an
insulated lunch bag is another great
option to keep that air inside the lunch
bag nice and cold as your kid is taking
it from the house to the lunchroom and
you know spending about a few hours in
between so frozen gel packs or you can
even use things like frozen water
bottles or frozen juice boxes or pouches
those things are going to be important
to keep your child's lunch cold which
will help keep it safe about how long
can you expect you send your kiddo off
let's say 7 a.m it'll make it through
the lunch hour okay
yes it should make it through the lunch
hour okay of course you want to keep in
mind that your kid is going on a field
trip or going outside and it's really
hot in your area that time is going to
be reduced so you may want to consider
packing an extra cold source just to
make sure there's enough in there to
really keep it cold a few hours until
lunch time but you're absolutely right
if you're trying to pack something
that's going to last till the end of the
day you may want to consider some
alternatives or just really packet full
of those cold sources so you have
adequate coverage for keeping it cold so
what are some other things that we maybe
just don't necessarily think of when it
comes to keeping food safe and fresh so
we don't get sick
so especially if you're you know parents
are busy they're trying to pack things
the night before maybe while also
cooking dinner that's you know great
options for time savers but just keeping
in mind that when you are preparing food
in your home you have to keep certain
things you know on top of mine so for
example if you're preparing your dinner
or something else and you're using raw
meat or poultry you also really want to
make sure that you're keeping those nice
and separate from any foods that are
ready to eat already cooked are going to
be cooked later on because that bacteria
from the raw meat and poultry can cross
contaminate onto your cooked foods and
we definitely don't want that because
that can lead to foodborne illness hand
washing is another big thing for a
back-to-school time frame not just for
lunch but just in general as kids are
getting back out and about and you know
touching a bunch of things and whatnot
so encouraging hand washing using it as
an educational opportunity for your kids
to teach them that it's always important
to wash their hands before they eat
their lunch if you know that your kid is
going on a field trip or somewhere else
where running water might not be readily
available packing hand sanitizer with at
least 60 alcohol content or any of those
moist towelettes are also great
alternatives to make sure hands are
clean before we eat
all the simple tips makes such a
difference meredith thank you so much
for joining us this morning we
appreciate it good advice